une autre est très solennelle et une
impression de palais de justice au sein
de l'ue vs cul pour ce procès simulé les
élèves du master 2 en droit pénal font
face à une juridiction quelque peu
particulière le doyen de la faculté mari
et ma boursiers scrute attentivement les
attitudes de ses étudiants c'est
vraiment les entraîner à sortir de même
à être en mesure de s'exprimer et de
s'exprimer dans un registre
professionnel consomment dans les
métiers du droit ou mia qui sont des
métiers qui sont assez traditionnel pour
beaucoup avec des milieux dans lesquels
il ya des codes savoir être de savoir
vivre tout simplement
les codes le savoir-être les attitudes
du monde judiciaire maremma boursiers
des pratiques depuis l'obtention d'un
dea la fin des années 90 cette
spécialiste du droit pénal ses traces et
ensuite un parcours presque parfait
docteur en 2002 maître de conférences un
an plus tard elle devient vice doyen en
2013 avant d'être élu doyen en juin
dernier fait vraiment un parcours un
parcours d'investissement dans des
fonctions administratives
j'ai été vice doyen précédemment et il y
à un moment où la décision en tout cas
se présentait de vouloir embrasser ses
fonctions se fait assez naturellement
comme le prolongement d'un parcours
désormais responsable d'une véritable
pme de 75 personnes enseignants
chercheurs et administratives compris
l'agenda de mari et ma boursiers et
faits d'arbitrage important et de
problématiques du quotidien on porte un
projet pour notre faculté qui évidemment
est en lien avec nous nos échéances
immédiates dans le cadre de paris-saclay
de faire rayonner son institution le
plus possible en portons les collègues
en lait en favorisant la recherche
et puis à côté cela il ya aussi un
travail beaucoup plus quotidiens qui est
un travail de gestion d'une structure de
75 personnes
avec son budget et donc on peut être
sollicité pour une problématique de
chauffage
élu pour cinq ans le doyen est surtout
chargé d'un dossier fil rouge
l'intégration de sa faculté au sein de
l'université paris saclay un colosse de
l'enseignement supérieur avec 19
établissements à son bord contre 2020 et
c'est une phase d'intégration
progressive pour une idée d'intégration
totale dans un grand espace et en espace
dans lequel il y aura un autre de
grandes écoles
deux autres universités dans laquelle
lui vs qui entrera et la faculté de
droit entrera donc pour nous l'enjeu est
évidemment de valoriser le plus possible
notre recherche et nos formations et d'y
trouver une place qui qui sera une place
confortable et qui permettra vraiment de
rayonner le mieux possible complexité
d'organisation volonté politique et
institutionnelle parfois vacillante le
projet paris saclay fait figure de
véritable boussole pour le quinquennat
de mari et ma boursiers un projet qui
sera sûrement bouclée quand un autre
doyen sera alors responsable de la
faculté de droit et de sciences
politiques de l'ue vs q